now at 14 though you knew to get
emancipated from your mother which again
we hand shook and it was a very
respectful so four point eight didn't
you go to a Crosby's house I had to live
with David Crosby for two months which
is crazy because David had his own
problem he was an interesting character
what is it like living with David Crosby
of Crosby Stills Nash and young one of
my friend got to go on tour with them
and I would freak out and I would freak
out over Neil Young I would love with
Neil Young I was just like okay that's
the coolest human being ever I'm such a
valley girl and he probably was like oh
god I can't imagine what it's like at 14
to be hanging out with Crosby Stills
Nash and young on tour with those guys
who are fantastic artists just cause we
ever say listen drew it's bedtime time
to go to sleep or yeah he did bad for
them they like had to take in this kid
and like they weren't parents themselves
and but you know what I have to say I
had just come out of being in an
institution for a year and a half and it
was a very severe lockdown like no
Hollywood rehab 30-day Malibu beach side
[ __ ] this was you know school of
hard knocks in the most severe way and
you're 13 and I'm 13 to 14 but I swear
to god it's what I needed you need each
way I was gonna be me without that year
and a half it's almost like joining the
military for a third route can't right
and you would get the boot all the time
and I hated it at first I had nothing
but freedom up until that point dancing
on tables at Helena's in Studio 54 in
limelight and every club on the planet
and partying it up doing whatever I
wanted whenever I wanted and all of a
sudden it was you have no freedom you
will figure out your life and you have
the best insurance policy ever ever so
you're staying here until we tell you
you've changed and it was so upsetting
at first but over the course of that
year and a half I left there like the
most humble person you could ever
imagine
right they saved your life didn't they
they saved my
so when people say hey you know all
these places are bad and this and that
they're full of [ __ ] because you had
that they were the parent you needed
they at least gave you rules and
regulations they did in a year and a
half what probably should have done over
the course of 18 years and I literally
left there thinking I will never take
anything for granted and did that really
not that you ever get over doing drugs
and drink it's always sort of in the
back of mind but did you stay away from
that stuff did they give you enough
tools to stay off of it they gave me a
lot more than like just don't do drugs
it was like we're gonna help you get out
there and live your own life they were a
part of the emancipation program they
worked with the state they said that
would be the healthiest would be the
best is we're gonna help you figure this
out so you can get out of here one day
and and live on your own